danke fest auf den boden da man hört oft
sofort klar machen
lasst mich doch immer junge und max max
ist reicht hauptlinie ich meine es ernst
verlieren sonst
oder es willkommen zu einer neuen folge
handicaps heute spiel ist so ich mache
die tastatur
nein ich mag die maus macht die tastatur
ist nicht da genau wir wechseln
sozusagen hab ich bin zusammen heute ich
die maus macht die tastatur
wir schauen wir wie das läuft wo willst
du hin willst du ihm gelingt zu stellen
normalroute am 1 diese läuft okay was
meinst du kannst nicht hin wenn da ich
kann dich heute hinein dann das aufgehen
was trägst du von links oder von rechts
davon orden nicht wir einfach comeback
zumal wir machen das wirklich so kojima
hsv ist sehr gut wenn wir das gewinnen
niemand geschafft diese keine ahnung
so lange gebe die an harte kost mit
nicht nur fakten
ihr habt es vielleicht gar nicht dass
man sich fielen aber dennoch gleich kurz
halt gern machen gehörte weiter hebt die
anderen deiner hand so und wir bewegen
uns hier maus bewegt sich was bewegt
sich und wir laufen wenn wir natürlich
ein team erwischen dann ist das mittel
verpackt aber weil ich ich will mal ganz
kurz mit der man sie trotzdem nächste
ich hatte nur eine war nicht der links
heute nicht gesehen hast du das gesehen
ich meine aber doch nicht schon fast für
einen kommen hier besser auskennt ist
eine meiner johann ich bestimmt hast du
jede runde einer original habe ich mir
das manchmal ein paar beide eine hand
oben lassen mich selbst hatte das könnte
es zu schaffen ist es
nach hält die augen auf ich hab dir
weiter weiter weiter weiter weiter
weiter weiter
oh ja ich habe bei den namen wenn wir
von kunst haben auf den boden gefallen
jedoch ein kompass sehr gut
doch jetzt ist die auf gold
dann erst ja wenn ich mit spielern ohne
wird sollte so unnötig das macht ja nur
angreifbar wenn man einfach in goldhelm
von chaim austauscht bisher ist kein
problem sondern das make up and had
attended a dent diese ständig gamestar
steinbronn butler handy handy und wie
immer leute können natürlich handycam
symbol bitte vorschlägen die kommentare
schreiben
der kompass zeigt in die richtung aus
sehr gut hat es bumm bumm bumm bumm bumm
ich springe auflaufen müsste es bei der
nächsten kampfszene auf unsere hände
oben halten
zoomen kann auch ein bisschen suchen
wohin ich den namen gebäude ja du hast
es eben draußen und jetzt gibt dem gibt
dem jetzt dem küste kommt die kurve erst
mal da ist es besser dass ich habe es
schon gegeben jungen gewinnen alter das
wird so nice der ting ting alter oper
der troubadour dennoch weiter
wir haben auch tnt sehr gut trainiert
und sind uns da ein kompass zeigt vor
leimen ist es ein problem ist es ein
problem
es wird er damit verstanden also leicht
mir sein das ist kein problem dann ist
es wahrscheinlich ein job wollte weil
wir damit so poser verarschen wollen
schaffen
bisher hatten wir eigentlich unsere
hände oben in der letzten szene
ich denke ich zuerst war da immer das
wichtigste ist dass man immer das f5
endlich mal nicht so ein perfektes team
dank wer weiß doch den boden da man ja
oft so hot gehen lassen wir machen kein
problem kein problem für die bußgeld
lasst mich doch immer man merkt den
bogen weiter auf die erhoffte umzug in
das das junge max ist reicht hauptlinie
ich meine es ernst für ihren sohn zu
verlieren junge diesem frühjahr auf dem
dfns wieder egal ist da und alles da
haben wir aufgenommen gute zeit 88
minuten ja eine spontan knackige folge
noch zeit für eine kleine armee von
heute ihr könnt gerne in die kommentare
schreiben
wenn ihr ideen habt für weitere handicap
games folgen oder etwa für roberto wäre
es auch noch ziemlich viele hier auf
diesem magischen zettel ich weiß mal
aufgeschrieben und ja also haben
bestimmt sechs in petto oder so was ihr
könnt gespannt sein
falls ihr euch fragt warum ich in
letzter zeit jeden tag video macht keine
ahnung ich bin auch selbst überrascht
aber es macht einfach spaß schafft geht
noch weiter so lasst ein leichter eine
positive bewertung job kommentare von
über 100 aus okay da dran